[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar on optimizing patient blood
management and the role of the
laboratory
i'm iva maria zoman product manager for
northern europe at ortho clinical
diagnostics and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
webinar is brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by ortho clinical
diagnostics
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation you can report your
problem by clicking on the ask the
question box located on the far left of
your screen
i'd like to now introduce our speaker
for today's webinar cecilia scarponi who
is the clinical liaison for emir at
orthoclinical diagnostics
for a complete biography please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
in the first part of the talk cecilia
will give you a brief introduction of
the concept of patient blood management
which plays a critical role in the
management of severely ill neonatal
cancer and elderly patients
she will then cover the so-called three
pillar matrix of patient blood
management
and discuss how the laboratory can make
a difference in patients outcomes
through effective patient blood
management programs and practices
i will now hand over to you cecilia
thank you thank you very much uh
well first of all uh good afternoon and
welcome to everyone uh as anticipated uh
just anticipated by eva here's the
agenda of today's webinar um i will
introduce the concept of patient slot
management then i will introduce the
three pillar metrics of pbm
as well as the role of the lab that the
lab can play in a patient block
management strategy
so let's now introduce
the patient blood management concept so
um here's the definition of patient
blood management by the society of the
advancement of blood management
so the timely application of
evidence-based medical and surgical
concepts designed to maintain hemoglobin
concentration optimize hemostasis and
minimize blood loss in an effort to
improve
patients outcomes
and these are keywords because
we can see that the definition presented
by the society for the advancement of
blood management as well as several
other definitions of patient blood
management have moved away from placing
the focus only on reducing the use of
blood components to the development of a
multi-disciplinary
and multimodal strategy centered on
patient outcome
reducing transfusions might be one of
the means but it's certainly not
the an end
thus patience of management has moved
from a product-centered approach
to a
patient-centered approach
um so the patient blood management
concept was introduced in 2005
and endorsed by the wh so in 2010
but uh many hospitals still seek
guidance with the implementation of pbm
in clinical
routine
so
as already anticipated
well certainly there are specific
patient populations that are more likely
impacted by an optimized blood
management
these include critically ill and icu
patients neonatal patients
oncology
patients as well as the elderly
so let's now uh speak about this three
pillar metrics of patient blood
management
well uh let's describe
all of them
first of all
as you can see optimizing hematopoiesis
is the first pillar
which means detecting and treating
anemia and iron deficiency
but also treating the underlying causes
and optimizing hemoglobin levels
the second pillar is managing anemia so
knowing the patient's bleeding history
to develop the appropriate management
plan
as well as estimating the individual's
tolerance to blood loss
but also optimizing the cardiopulmonary
function
the third pillar is minimizing bleeding
and blood loss
and this is
meaning identifying managing and
treating bleeding and bleeding risk
including coagulation testing which is
not detailed in this presentation
also minimizing phlebotomy and plan and
rehearse
different procedures so through all
these three pillars we can say that
indeed the lab can have an impact on
each pillar and each strategy belonging
to these pillars
so
uh well first of all um the lab uh
we we have seen that one of the
strategies is detecting
erythrocytopenia and iron deficiencies
and
while the demand of unnecessary testing
should be avoided the clean lab has a
range of tests available to support
clinicians in diagnosing anemia and i
want to say that also vitro's anemia
panel include essays
that really perfectly fits uh this
indication like uh vitamin b12 and b12
and folate as well as a direct total
iron binding capacity but also iron and
ferritin
so there is an important aspect here uh
to to to take into account which is
estrogenic anemia so the development of
anemia due to medical procedures is an
universal concern among critically ill
patients anemia is common in critical
ill patients admitted to the itu to the
intensive care unit with 90 percent of
patients having an abnormally low
hemoglobin level by their third day of
of stay
um
half of them
would require uh ultimately a
transfusion and critically ill patients
are at particular risk for adverse
consequences from anemia given the
cardiovascular respiratory and metabolic
compromise frequently encountered
during critical illness
while phlebotomy and blood testing to
inform clinical decision making is vital
strategies have been developed to
minimize unnecessary yet regenerative
blood loss
and although blood draws can be
dramatically reduced by the use of blood
conservation strategies research
suggests that
they are not widely practiced in all
adults pediatric and neonatal icu
patients and departments
[Music]
so um
[Music]
let's have a closer look now at the
impact of phlebotomy on patient block
management
well
the amount of blood circulating in
within an individual depends on the body
structure as well as the weight but on
average a human adult has nearly five
liters of circulating blood
the large number of icu patients who
develop anemia and the contribution of
blood taken for diagnostic testing to
its development
is a long-standing concern
so just to give you some some figures i
mean patients who develop anemia
obviously as we said uh have poorer
outcomes and higher risk of mortality
whether or not uh patients are confused
so
previous reports uh of blood volume
drone from politically ill adult
patients average between 41 and
377 milliliters per day which is huge
the described daily average
blood sampling volume varied
well obviously depending on population
studied the length of stay evaluated but
also the methodology of the study
the highest volumes are commonly
encountered in the immediate post
operative period
and reaching up to
616 milliliters
well phlebotomy related blood loss is
even more profound and consequential um
in neonatal icu patients
these infants
indeed lose 10 to 90 percent of
circulating blood volume to phlebotomy
in the first two weeks of their life
so and it's also at the end finally
worth noting that most of the blood
grown for lab testing is discarded at
the end
so now um let's speak again at the
role that the relab can play in pbn
progress
so
i'd like to highlight the australian
national blood authority definition of
patient blood management approach
so
this approach requires identification of
critical opportunities in the continuum
of patient care
the coordination between different
disciplines that can reduce the
likelihood that a patient will require
an allergenic blood transfusion so
strategies aim that minimization of
blood loss should be considered as part
of rooting blood conservation
efforts so a key element of pbm is
prevention of blood being unnecessarily
drained from patients by reducing
phlebotomy blood loss within daily lab
analysis and this can be achieved in
several ways in different ways but here
i want to highlight four of them
first of all minimizing sample test
volume
secondly
when sampling bod flematovis
should use the smallest possible
collection tube size for the required
analysis
in addition reduction of the number of
collection tubes can be achieved and
using a technique
to uh that allows using a technology
that allows to get results right the
first time is also a crucial aspect
let's uh then detail all these uh all
these four different ways and aspects
so first minimizing sample test volumes
so
well as shown in this picture now i'm
focusing on pediatric patients so blood
collection and lab testing in these
pediatric populations present multiple
challenges as you all know so draw
volume limitations vein collapse and
access collapse
high imaginary
labeling issues as well
so
many of these
challenges resulting in low or
insufficient serum fat or plasma volumes
that are available for testing and
potentially also uh trigger and no
results no reportable lab results which
is even more dramatic
so on um
the graphs on the top right aside gives
an idea of the elevated number of tests
that are performed on an extremely low
body weight incense i i remind you less
than one kilo
weight
and these uh include particularly
electrolyzed glucose really rubin being
the most common test so as you can see
it may go up to 150
tests that are required uh and also
these increase
depending on the length of stay of the
hospital in in the
icu
so um
a series of of beatrice
xt microslides with dual test capability
has been developed
intended to reduce sample size uh and
while at the same time maintaining
analytical performance versus the
conversional uh single essay size
so as we can see in this table uh here
the total
sample volume required for the most
common pediatric tests
is 77.5
micro liters
thanks to the slide and it's even lower
when double slides so xt microslides are
used so it's around 60 microliters which
is really a tiny little amount
[Music]
so
uh in addition to that a feature
vitros technology includes uh smart
metering features that automatically
check for bubbles and cloths or debris
whenever present in a sample
so this would ensure
that the sample integrity is maintained
and would guarantee that results are
correct there is an additional feature
which is which we call save the sample
which is really particularly useful
whenever the sample volume is limited
and so pressure particularly in
pediatric samples but not only limited
to them
and this is that whenever the the
proboscis or the
the sample uh metering would uh detect
insufficient or any issue uh in the
sufficient sample or bubbles or cloths
then they will return the sample into
the tube and this is uh very useful for
limited uh samples
now let's um
see and look at the second way to
improve patient blood management in
using which is using a small sample
volume
so
indeed the use of small sample volumes
aims to minimize phlebotomy volume
and and is really uh important so indeed
routing use of small sample volumes in
the icu
significantly has proven to
significantly reduce
the volume of blood loss due to
diagnostic testing without adversely
affecting lab
operations and these might ultimately
reduce the transfusion requirements
which are associated to uh elevated
risks for patients as well as as well as
costs okay
um
the use of smaller tubes may reduce also
the severity of the motor induced anemia
without again compromising the lab test
procedures
so
really small tubes are one of the
components of the crucial components
that
can impact patient blood management
focusing now on vitro's platforms uh i
want to mention that vitro systems uh
have a universal sample trays that can
accommodate a variety of collection
tubes including micro collection
containers micro cups with volumes as
more or less 0.5 milliliters or 2
milliliters cup
but even smaller containers and
small sample volume
tubes are compatible with vitreous
automation solution with minimal impact
on the lab operations as i mentioned
so another aspect of blood conservation
strategies is reducing the number of
collection tubes
so whenever possible consolidating exams
on a single tube involves an adequate
choice
of of uh well i would say is is the
preferred choice okay
um vitro60 integrated systems enable the
consolidation of analysis in a unique
tube and this is fundamental
this obviously uh it also goes with a
low debt volume that is required uh as
well as
no extra sample that are
that is required to evaluate
sample quality indices hemolysis
hectares and lipina which i will detail
and speak about a little bit later
and uh
obviously uh i'd like to empha emphasize
that vitro's automation and i.t
solutions enable
intelligent rules to handle testing
orders
direct sample from primary tubes but
also a fast release
of the tube that can be used in other
systems standalone systems uh for
further uh testing and analysis
here i want to
bring you uh a real uh i mean a case a
study uh and a customer experience uh so
first of all let's let's let's allow me
to give some some context in 2020
there is a lab
in in
france
that uh have replaced four uh
stand-alone uh instruments with a
features automation solution which was
comprising two um vitros xt 7600
integrated systems
so um this was the the change and the
activity to the an idea in 2021 was an
average of 570 patients per day
this change triggered a redesign of the
laboratory workflow
and in particular
there were
different different um
changes that were applied so first of
all there was a reduction of specimens
from six to three so uh half of them
um and a consolidation of chemistry and
immunoassays in one single primary tube
uh secondly some essays uh required an
internal validation uh and correlation
so that
uh the serum testing could be replaced
by plasma testing and this is the case
for vitamin d
um
the adoption of a specific tubes which
are uh bd
for uh 3.5 milliliter plasma lithium
heparin shoes
um
also allowed
or triggered a lot of improvements
specifically these tubes do have a
mechanic separation and a reduction of
platelets in the plasma
these end up uh contributing to reduce
the hemolysis from 2.1 percent rate with
sirin to 1.4 rate with vd uh barricore
3.5 ml plasma tubes
uh well in addition thanks again to the
v-source technology um water triggered
uh
interferences were completely eliminated
as well as uh sample uh cross
contamination
thanks to the use of disposable tips so
this is a an example where uh merging uh
the different tube uh manufacturers
together with a technology would really
uh contribute in um in in saving as you
can see here or or getting to the impact
the huge impact of
25 000 tubes per year reduction
which is a quantum leap
change
let's now um
see the last contributor of the
reduction of diagnostic associated blood
laws uh which is getting the right
results uh the first time which is a
crucial aspect
well um analytical errors
may trigger sample reruns and represent
a common challenge
um some samples uh
of very common into some examples sorry
of very common interferences are
hemolysis x-rays and lipemia which can
impact multiple parameters as listed in
the table here
these interferences often linked to
sample quality are a common thread to
the laboratory
which is often by the way underestimated
but uh well however beside actors uh in
in in inter equals in uh hemosis and and
the feminine uh there are beside these
there are other
common interferences can be water
contamination and there are many other
potential interferences with which may
lead to erroneous results to main few of
them paraproteins specific drugs
like naturalized and hemi beats or known
as ancestral electrolyte exclusion
effect
febrine cloth but also risk of carryover
or eterophedic antibodies are quite
common
interferences uh definitely
analytical errors are a reason to worry
but uh let me give you some reasons now
not to worry and and give you specifics
on how we overcome these challenges
well um microslides bring a solution to
interferences uh thanks to its
technology uh the challenge of hemolysis
uh icteros and lipinia can occur on
average uh in about seven seven sorry a
percent of samples
in the emergency department this could
even go up to thirty percent of amoled
samples uh so this is a white quite
common and an impacting issue the vitro
solution uh
is the spreading layer
that could really trap a moblobin
bidirubin or lipids eventually present
so for most of the chemistry testing the
impact of
hil is either completely avoided or at
least strongly minimized
for uh our homogeneous and heterogeneous
immunoassays we have the micro sensor
technology
which measure the potential impacts of
of muscle ethers and and and turbidity
by taking a gnostic reading of the dead
volume of the sample so if there is a
potential for interference the result it
would be flagged and
the lab personal will be awarded would
be would be
aware sorry
so um another challenge uh is the
so-called electrolyte exclusion effect
which can lead to misclassification of
critical care patients as a consequence
of incorrect sodium or potassium results
we have seen earlier that
electrolytes are part of the pediatric
menu
especially at the neonatal intensive
care unit so our crucial essays
so on the left side of the slide
you can see
what can happen with indirect ion
selective
electrodes for which samples are diluted
as long as the sample have normal
protein or lipid levels this is fine
it's okay but for samples with an
increased protein level
like often the case with cancer patients
this result is is in a more dilute
liquid phase and the concentration of
electrolytes can be underestimated
on the other way when the protein level
is abnormally low for example it's often
the case of critically ill patients the
electrolyte concentration could be
overestimated and on the right side the
virtual solution that is presented here
to this issue is the use of direct uh
isis
where samples are not diluted so
another advantage that comes with the
use of this slide format is that
there are no electrodes to to maintain
and calibrations are stable for a very
long time
six months or even up to one year
um
we there there is another challenge that
we can look at which is the potential
impact of paraproteins which
particularly affect uh elderly patients
i must say
many case studies that you can see
detailed here have been published about
incorrect results in a variety of assays
due to paraproteins
with wet chemistry in particular but
again
here uh with a spreading layer on top of
our multi-layer microslide paraproteins
would be
captured
and do not
interfere in the reaction and do not
impact the final result
another extremely
common uh
aspect so last but not least i want to
mention um is how poor
water quality
and impurities generally can lead to
inaccurate results and a variety of
different assays that you see detail
here so again electrolytes but also
amylase uh lactose dio hydrogenase
as well as phosphorus and so on
so
the solution
resides simply in a completely waterless
technology so there is no connection to
any water drain uh plus there is no uh
need for use
of of water at all
getting close uh to the the summary of
this presentation uh at court i want to
mention that we have these six unique
vitreous technologies
which are the core of the vitreous
analyzer and as i've just described
they all contribute delivering high
quality results which end up affecting
at the end
definitely get it right the first time
and ultimately patient blood management
avoiding
reruns avoid and improving turnaround
time
whenever whenever possible
let me
now uh conclude with few takeaways which
i find crucial
well first of all
patient blood is a valuable and unique
resource
that should be preserved and managed
appropriately
reducing volume
and or the number of collected blood
samples
samples
is part of the overall blood loss
control strategy
but the nice part is that you're not
every lab can make a difference in
patients outcome
through
the application of effective patient
blood management practices and
strategies
so
future solutions encompassing small
sample volume
thanks to microslide technology but also
an efficient workflow
supports patient blood management by
reducing reruns
reducing sample volume and also the
number of tubes that are required for
most routine diagnostic tests
thank you for your attention i now hand
over to eva
to the moderator to see whether we have
received questions i would be glad to
answer too
thank you very much cecilia for this
great presentation
i would like to open up the floor for
questions now so if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for today so
let's get started cecilia you mentioned
different strategies that could
contribute preserving patient blood
are there pre-operative lab testing
indications to evaluate the patient's
hemorrhagic risk and eventually the need
for a blood transfusion
oh well yes indeed
i think
a thorough
pre-surgery
patient evaluation is crucial
to improve patient blood management and
moreover to assess
any any bleeding disorder
a complete anemia assessment which
include hemoglobin but also amostasis
and coagulation tests like prothrombin
time
complete blood cell count
and including platelets
are extremely helpful i would say in
identifying a static defect that could
that could then
cause an excessive bleeding so
knowing the patients
thoroughly before
[Music]
would really reduce minimize the risk
of bleeding and all the negative
consequences uh and and we have seen
that particularly just after um
surgery
patients may be subjected to
many diagnostic tests and therefore
anticipating any any
possible
bleeding disorder disorder really is
crucial
very interesting
question
great thank you cecilia
so cecile you also described the lab
experience in france ending up with a
really impressive reduction of the
number of tubes used were there
additional effects of the implemented
changes
oh well yes i made it short in the
presentation but indeed there were many
positive side effects to that experience
well the lab personnel
highlighted that the improved workflow
allowed to streamline logistic aspects
linked to tube storage
handling disposal as well as to better
handle the peak time
um
due to start a sample so short
turnaround time samples because the
routine uh flow was was really handled
uh in a more efficient way
in addition
this combination uh that i described in
between bd uh barricader tubes that
reduce the sample hemolysis thanks to an
appropriate vacuum uh
technique uh but also uh a very thorough
um training of the personal the
prostrobotomies
um
would
together combination together with the
beatrice technology which is as i
mentioned assessing the sample quality
reducing the
impact of the molecules on test results
so this combination was really
addressing both the pre-analytical and
the analytical aspects that could really
negatively impact uh turnaround time
so i think it's an overall
very nice experience plus
really concretely
shows that reducing the number of tubes
is possible
thanks to
really a new rethinking or a paradigm
shift with the aim with a focus in mind
of
patient blood management
thank you cecilia great answer so as we
learned today specific patient
populations are deserving an increased
focus on patient blood management
aspects
so there's a question if you have any
further insights based on your
experience
well yes well first of all
while all patients
deserve definitely equal attention i
must say that oncology patients are
probably highly
impacted
due
first of all to the number of samples to
sample tubes that are required
for regular
monitoring of those patients as well as
the potential
impact of drugs uh on the lab results so
many drugs could interfere with um with
with
samsung tests some laboratory tests as
well as
paraproteins can be present as we have
seen and briefly described before
so also
hemodialyzed patients i would say uh are
are well um
as well are undergoing uh frequent
assessments of the renal functions
so patient blood management is
definitely a common objective
among a variety of different fragile
patients and different medical scenarios
again thank you for this interesting uh
question i would like to be more
exhaustive but i think that um every
every lab has its own experience on uh
and depending on the population that is
served but indeed uh i think that we are
not all equal not all patients are equal
facing patient block management
strategies and focus
thanks very much cecilia
so this concludes our session for today
before we go i'd like to thank cecilia
and of course our audience for joining
us today
questions we didn't answer today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
author's purpose is to improve and save
lives through diagnostics because every
test is alive for more information about
ortho please visit our website at
orthoclinicaldiagnostics.com
you can also view the webinar on demand
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
stay healthy and safe and we're looking
forward to seeing you at one of our next
webinars soon take care
thank you
bye
you